jetzt mal etwas außer der reihe melina
in scope 21 minister tesch back mike
singer kong crafter felix pfander laden
sie die zimmer rallys ich könnte ohne
ende weitermachen mit dem login es
werden die besten die tollsten die
phaeno sensationell mental fantastisch
trillian besten videos aller zeiten das
ist das einzige event weltweit mit einer
solch großen show verbunden mit einem
riesigen community event und ich habe
wieder days tickets zu sonderkonditionen
für jeden von euch wirklich jeder kann
sie war ein link und einen code mit
einem sonderrabatt bekommen infos dazu
gleich am ende zum zehnten mal finden
sie statt und die community steht im
mittelpunkt wir bringen bekannte
gesichter der ersten stunde aufstrebende
künstler und die größten fan communitys
deutschland zusammen es wird einen
riesigen community bereich geben wo es
ohne ende coole aktionen und youtuber
zum anfassen geben wird übrigens welche
aktion soll ich da machen also ich freue
mich auf ideen anregungen und vorschläge
schreibt sie in die kommentare
die zehnte video days werden der
absolute hammer es wird wieder golden
plate buttons für alle youtuber geben
die im letzten jahr die eine million
marke überschritten haben es wird eine
coole show mit mega xvii skk melina ist
dabei die timor ellis aus den usa mike
singer lukas riga basel melodie aus
großbritannien und vielen vielen vielen
anderen geben es ist also für jeden
wirklich jeden etwas dabei nur auf dem
video des und das ist wirklich weltweit
einmalig gibt es diese riesige show und
jetzt habe ich weiß auch nicht wie es
kommt ein ganz besonderes angebot für
euch erst mal könnt ihr hier tickets
gewinnen
es gibt fünf mal zwei tickets für die
beiden tage die normalen video des
tickets 2 x 2 tickets mit denen ihr zwei
wahnsinns tage erlebt und ein
garantiertes mitbekommt und 2 x 2
superstar tickets die zu den zwei tagen
live event euch gleich zwei meet greets
mit euren lieblings saß sichern alles
was er machen muss ist die vielleicht
nicht ganz leichte fragen zu beantworten
in welcher location finden die video der
ist dieses jahr in köln statt schickt
die antwort bitte an tricks gmail.com
und ich drücke natürlich die 1000
einsendeschluss ist der 15
juli für alle die es nicht abwarten
können und sich ein ticket sichern
wollen gibt es einige
klicks um sonderrabatt zehn prozent auf
alle tickets klickt auf diesen link der
ist auch in der video beschreibung video
days punkt eu / tickets und geht den
rabattcode fliegst du bei sonderaktionen
wie so days ein und schon bekommt ihr
tickets billiger ich freue mich auf euch
und auf die wirklich phänomenal
sensationell fantastischen video days
aller zeiten
bis dann bleib dran